Hi, welcome to the Anti-National Show. I'm Ann and I'm Ashley and today we're going to be talking about natural deodorants versus conventional deodorants. But before we get started on today's episode, please share, like, subscribe to these videos. If you're on YouTube, you can hit the little notification button or the alert button and it'll send you an alert when we have these episodes, so you are sure to never miss any of them.
Again, we're talking about deodorant today, which is something that we need to think about because it's something that we use every day. There's lots of different kinds up there, you know, termed as natural, so it can be a very confusing field.
And there are lots, there are a lot and it can be very overwhelming if you just go and look at the shelf of them. So with the term natural, what that means is it's going to not be advertised as an anti-perspirant. So it'll just be a natural deodorant, which means they use ingredients like baking soda, aloe, arrowroot, coconut oil, different types of clays, cornstarch, and then organic alcohol as well.
In their products or their ingredients in the product. And now it's just going to be able to absorb this sweat, not necessarily being anti-perspirant.
So there's lots of different brands out there that are considered clean, ingredientless brands. And often I think of deodorants kind of like you want a pair of jeans, you know, lots of great brands out there but you can tell you try a lot of different things, you need to try different things in order to find the one that's right for you.
So, you know, some people could have reactions to different ingredients, the sodium bicarbonate, and some of them maybe you could have, somebody could have a reaction to just a skin reaction that does not happen to me.
But a few of the brands that I have tried, I've tried Tom's, I've tried Schmidt's, I've tried Native, I haven't tried the goddess, but I've tried primarily pure.
The Jason brand is another one that I've tried. And I keep coming back to, and now this is the one that I've been using for over a year now, is the Native brand.
So again, you just have to try different ones that are, you know, low on that toxicity scale. So until you find the one that works for you. So Native is the one that works best for me as far as keeping older at bay and then also absorbing the sweat.
So, when we talk about the toxic scale, the ingredients that we're looking to avoid are going to be aluminum because that can block the sweat duct. And then we also have the TEA and the DEA.
And those have actually been banned in Europe because the carcinogen affects. The other piece that we want to avoid is going to be fragrances. And that's of course to make, I mean, America is just like, oh, we need to smell good consolation.
We need to add fragrance and a lot of things, which the natural fragrance from essential oils are great, obviously, but the synthetic ones are where they can be more damaging long term use.
And again, we're putting it in an area where our lymph nodes are and it can absorb them. So if you're not sweating, you're absorbing everything that you're supposed to be detoxing.
So those toxic ingredients are actually in our mainstream line of products such as Dove, Secret, Axe, Old Spice.
That's what I've always used is Dove or Secret. And I know men always use Axe, of course, with those commercials.
They have their old spice. Yeah, they definitely smell good. But again, the synthetic fragrances, they can disrupt hormones and cause problems. We don't want to be doing that.
And again, like you said in the under armpit area, right where those lymph nodes are, it's just a delicate area where you don't want to be absorbing those toxins.
And I, previous to using a natural brand, I used the Secret Clinical Strength. I even had a prescription from the dermatologist for, I don't even remember what it's called.
But I'm really high. I also made aluminum. And it totally worked. I did not sweat. But Alzheimer's disease runs in my family.
Aluminum across with the blood brain barrier can get lodged in the brain and cause some, I mean, it's been light. So I can show that aluminum can be tied to Alzheimer's disease.
So I do not want to put that on my body. And just for fun yesterday, I plugged in the Secret Clinical Strength into the Think Dirty app.
So it's an app that you can download and you can plug in your products, your current products that you're using and it will give you a toxicity rating between zero and 10 zero is obviously the least toxic 10 is the most toxic.
And the Secret Clinical Strength was an eight on the toxicity scale. So pretty high, yeah, super high. Between an eight and a 10 is considered a high potential of long-term health risks, negative health risks associated with those ingredients.
So, yeah, so that's pretty scary. And then when I plugged in the native deodorant, it comes up as a one.
And I think we're between a zero and a three, there's no ingredients in that product that are harmful to health. So yeah, I made it.
I'm actually works for me as well as the native. I know our co-workers have mentioned they it doesn't work for them, the native and they use schmitz or tongs or something else again like she said, it's not one size fits all.
If I'm the works for you and what works best, the God is when I've tried and I do like this one, it is a detoxifier at the same time. It has essential oils in it as well for the scent.
So what I did was I started, I had dove. And then I started with this one is my tester of natural deodorant. And I liked it, but then I went to this one for about two weeks or so.
And it started drying toxins out from the detoxing effect, which is great, but that pit detox is going to be more powerful this one here.
For drying things out, then just the goddess on the loan. Yes. So a lot of times people will use this when they're transitioning from a conventional remains streamed deodorant to our natural one.
There is a kind of a process that your body has to go through in order for the natural deodorants to be effective for you. So the pit tox can help speed up that process. So it's just kind of like a stab that you put on your armpits.
So it's it for 20 minutes and it pulls all the toxins can unplug those sweat glands that we have been blocking for all of these years with our mainstream deodorant.
So it unplugs those gets rid of the toxins and then you can start with your natural deodorant. You don't have to do that. I never did that, but it sounds great. I didn't know about it when I started this one.
And they have similar effect. You may experience a detox reaction with this one. I know for this one too, it's like maybe a rash will occur because it's drying things out.
And it can be like a burning sensation when you leave it on. That's what one of our coworkers had mentioned who loves it and swears by it.
So again, I've not tried that yet, but that sounds like a good idea. Right. And I feel like some people can do this just on a periodic basis. And that means we're deodorant.
Right. I don't want that. Yeah, that's not me. And excessive sweaters. So if you're an excessive sweater, your pores might be just really pushing the detoxing.
And so doing some type of detox in the underarm that will it has with the people we've talked to help them with that.
And they either have minimal sweating now or they don't have any.
So it's really, it's really cool.
It makes their own kind of activity.
Yeah. So those are our experiences of these.
So hopefully you found this information helpful. If you have any questions, just feel free to reach out either through social media.
You can call our clinic. We do nutrition consultations, genetic consultations.
The first 15 minutes is always free.
So feel free to take advantage of that. So be sure to like our video, share the video, subscribe to our channel and pass this video along to people you may know who are interested in more natural personal hygiene.
Crystal Hydrean.
Hydraean.
Yeah, me too. Hydraeans.
Hydraeans, I have them all.
Yeah. Personal hygiene products.
Thank you for watching.